you could go to bed with Nigel Farage  and wake up with Edmund van NEC the SNP  dick from level in Scotland is a chance  of David Cameron clinging on to power  hiya from Sky News it's all very  confusing at the moment isn't it a lot  of politicians are saying if you vote  for them you actually get them at labor  of saying you know who it s MP you get  Tories would save you then you get on a  deeper than this yeah you end up with  where's the line good and I can't even  really a signal does it sort of put your  voting in a way is this yeah is it yeah  cuz you don't know what you're gonna get  yeah  that your heart set on one party then  fine yeah if you want it tactically  books and it's very difficult if it's me  off I bet to see ya looks like one  person came one thing you've got  somebody else into something else it  might even well i hope that shot is in  some way that's the way it helped  confused keyboard I tried okay thank you  very much